les chéris jean michel mr et ce soir
avec sa dulcinée
ouais j'ambitionne mère et sa famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
je suis très ému évidemment parce que ça
je suis très ému parce que c'est vrai
que c'est longtemps que c'était secret
ou aujourd'hui c'est officiel donc c'est
vrai que c'est un nouveau départ
bon ben ça serait mieux je pense alors
on va dire la vérité ça n'est pas à ces
nuls faisait beaucoup trop chic pour lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et beaucoup mieux que ce que vous croyez
puisque ce n'est pas sa fille la fiancée
de jean michel maire mais c'est la femme
d'un ami très proche un ami que j'aime
qui voulait lui faire une surprise ce
soir et vous êtes la femme 2
[Applaudissements]
la femme que j'adore j'aime très fort
c'est d'ailleurs venu au mariage et je
reviendrai à toutes les fêtes parce que
je suis une barrette de golf que j'adore
les fêtes et n'est pas venu juste pour
te voir parce qu'elle sait que tu
travailles
elle voulait pas vérifier si tu étais là
ta femme avait quelque chose à te dire
tu peux tu es magnifique merci qu'est-ce
que je l'aimais en monsieur rigoler mais
regarde le chichi regarde l'honnetete
mullings a aujourd'hui je crois tu es m
2 tanner une à toi une attaque
[Applaudissements]
alors mon bébé mon bébé ta femme
voudrait pas je te quitte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ému mais c'est dur non c'est trop mignon
donc voilà je voulais profiter de cette
émission parce que je sais que je suis
tient beaucoup à cette émission donc
cyril m'a laissé venir pour pouvoir te
faire une petite déclaration
donc j'ai préparé un petit poème pour
toi donc avec des lettres de ton prénom
donc voilà donc m comme mariage ça fait
déjà cinq ans ont des mariés donc merci
aux com
or comme les noces d'or donc j'espère
qu'on pourra un jour j'étais nos noces
d'or t comme tunisie le on sait à part
dans les vosges les plus nombreux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme tom dawn est morte à fait le cas
comme tiff en fait comme je kiffe grave
la vie avec toi montée comme tunisie
parce que c'est le premier lieu on s'est
trouvés ces rencontres et a comme ayyub
donc notre enfant preuve de notre amour
et d air pur restons unis quoi qu'il
arrive
bon sauf si jean michel maire ne
détourne mais là non je te parlais de
plus tard voilà je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est leurs 50 ans de mariage cinq
ans de mariage
au fait ce week end willow est ce que
vous avez la piscine la piscine
bref à toi boulevard mais pour moi c'est
kate
[Applaudissements]
ces termes est ce que je peux m'occuper
de votre week-end moi même je vous fais
qui fait je serais pas là je vais pas
venir non alors est ce que j'ai vraiment
ma place dans ces cinq ans de mariage
je pose la question de l'adhésion tête
je ne sais pas si j'ai ma place j'ai
fait que je vienne je viendrai attendez
laissez le tranquille jours déjà de
notre réunion on part vous inquiétez pas
je m'en occupe d'accord on va passer
tout le week-end a kiffé bon je sais
vous allez kiffer et moi je vous revois
je regarderai je suis un organisateur
d'accord en facilitateur 1 1
j'ai envie de vous faire kiffer ce
week-end d'accord c'est bon ayadi je
kiffe tous les goûts avec toi des mots
[Musique]
cheryl est trop mignon
je vous souhaite beaucoup de bonheur et
c'est son initiative elle voulait
absolument que tu faire une surprise ce
soir à l'isi qui file à la ne te connais
pas content il est pudique
oui bah oui c'est pas c'est pas jean
michel c'est sûr qu'il y ait ce week-end
c'est que du ctif et je vous aime très
fort vous savez je vous lâcherai jamais
tous les deux vous le savez jamais non
mais c'est sûr il faut aussi je sais que
les paris voilà donc on est on
maintenant on a trois on reste à la
merci des allées